Trees have a lot of properties
that make them useful.
However, a tree is really just
an extension of a linked list.
A linked list has one
element at the front and
a next pointer to another element,
and so on.
A tree is similar.
The first element is called the root.
Instead of having just one next element,
a tree can have several.
A linked list is often
drawn horizontally, but
a tree is normally drawn
vertically like this.
Just like a linked list, each element
on a tree contains some data.
The individual elements in a tree that
contain values are often called nodes.
Let's add a few more constraints
on what we call a tree.
First of all,
a tree must be completely connected.
That means,
if you're starting from the root,
there must be some way to
reach every node in the tree.
Here is an example of unconnected nodes.
So this definitely isn't a tree.
Next, there must not be
any cycles in the tree.
A cycle occurs when there's a way for
you to encounter the same node twice.
For example, in this tree there
is a connection back to the root.
If I start at the root,
then I'll get back to the root.
The same goes for this tree.
If you ignore the arrows,
you can still go in a circle.
This counts as a cycle.
So beware.